hey man stop bashing fergie okay you
asked Fergie to do the national anthem
at the NBA beta basketball at the NBA
[ __ ] national anthem guess what guess
what you got Fergie
man you got Fergie that's what you got
she [ __ ] killed that [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] what you say she did it in
her Fergie way okay
you didn't ask Andrea Bocelli to sing
that [ __ ]
you didn't ask these [ __ ] to do
it
you made Fergie and then asked her to
sing the national anthem and then didn't
like what she did [ __ ] that you made
your bed lay in it you clapped
[ __ ] like Ray Charles did it you
clapped [ __ ] behind your
keyboard oh she broke in took a chance
she sings let's get [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you order pizza you're
getting pizza if you order a [ __ ]
burrito you get a burrito you can't
order a burrito and then get a burrito
and be like what's this [ __ ] all
wrapped up with the [ __ ] beans and
chicken you [ __ ] you asked for that
[ __ ] you asked for that [ __ ] you as you
bought her albums you bought
Fergalicious you made her a part of the
Black Eyed Peas
and then she sings a national anthem and
she did still the country song the way
you wanted get the [ __ ] go to lunch go
to [ __ ] lunch dude this is
unbelievable this is the moment this is
the moment where everything [ __ ] make
everything makes sense to me you
[ __ ] are mad that Fergie didn't
do the national anthem like you wanted
her to dude I watched that [ __ ] thing
I watched it I watched that [ __ ] thing
I looked it up on YouTube and she sang
it and the whole time I shook my head
and I the whole time I go yup yup yup
yup that's what the [ __ ]
doctor ordered that's what I said out
loud to nobody after I knew that
everyone got upset about it that's what
the doctor ordered man